[Applause]
when you
when you learn or study all day or you
work on your business
your brain doesn't shut off at night
it's actually more active
and it's what is it doing it's
consolidating your short to long-term
memory it's integrating all the things
that you've learned and
it's coming up with ideas like these
gems like when you dream
we'll probably spend like 20 years of
our life sleeping
maybe three to five full years dreaming
three to five years that's a lot of time
right it's so insane to think about it
yeah it's 25 years knocked out
that's it it is right and so three to
five years dreaming
and you're dreaming like i i mentioned
this
like last night that mary shelley came
up with frankenstein in her dream yeah
paul mccartney came up with a song
yesterday in his dream yeah you know
elias howe created this sewing machine
his dream a chemist created the periodic
table dream what are we dreaming about
and so sometimes i dream and i bomb on
stage yeah yeah i'm not
finding my masterpiece at home
i gotta not do that joke but imagine
like using that intestine
intention of waking up at a certain time
and you do it just to kind of prog
maybe like i don't know a program is a
weird word but just asking yourself a
question
that you really want to know the
solution for and let your brain work on
it throughout the night
and maybe you happen to dream about
those things so
that's what i do when i wake up in the
morning i um the first thing i do
actually is remember my dreams i feel
like that i just
if my dreams are there i have a i just
have right by my nightstand i'm curious
what you have about your nightstand
it's like i have a glass of water a book
a fiction reading book that i read
sometimes before i go to bed because i
don't want to read anything like
real heady and get my executive brain
but fiction is a nice way of
decompressing
and i have like a little journal like
nothing fancy a little notebook but i
just write my dreams in there each
morning okay and it trains myself
to pay attention to my dreams have you
heard of this uh
idea of lucid dreaming yeah i've
actually done it really
in like pretty intense ways naturally if
you're a kid
yeah just naturally like fly when i want
to and i've been able and
it's quite often what happened to me in
a dream is i'll go oh i'm dreaming
oh cool and sometimes i can go i know
i'm dreaming so it's time to fly and i
just fly and there's some times where i
go i know i'm dreaming
yeah fly and i can't you can
why yeah yeah yeah well first of all if
people listening to this they might be
seeming like really weird because
they've never experienced this
they call it lucid dreaming this isn't
that common people don't no
it's it it it is common for some people
but not often for a lot of really they
never experienced so
lucid means you're aware and so lucid
dreaming is you're aware that you're
asleep and dreaming
and uh and some people do it naturally
right and for those who don't do it
naturally
like anything else you could train
yourself to be able to do it and it's
wonderful because if you're spending
three to five
years of your life dreaming then you can
pick up that time
and you know what can you do you live
out fantasies you can meet people you
can learn things you go on adventures do
all these things
and still get the restorative benefit of
sleep right so it's
wonderful and one of the tricks that we
talk about to
lucid dream i did a podcast episode on
this is just train yourself throughout
the day
ask yourself this simple question is
this a dream
so simple right yourself 100 here
a day and then the first time the answer
is yes
then you're lucid dreaming right because
remember you obsess about something
you know throughout the day and you
start dreaming about it yeah but if you
start asking yourself that question or
you start looking at your hand
and just like every time you look at
your hand just think about your dreams
and then when you look at your hand you
know when you're when you're
in a dream and yeah reminds you of that
but um so i write down my dreams and i
get
these little these little gems and then
the second thing i do
when i get up is i i actually don't get
out of bed i don't touch my phone
all right because i think successful
people we all have a to-do list yeah
everybody who's listening you have your
to-do list but i think the people that
are
like really make guy crushing it they
also have like a not-to-do list
you know whether it's explicit or it's
just something that they just won't
these non-negotiables that it's there's
this book
good to great by jim collins says you
have to say no to good
so you could say yes to what's on your
not to-do list yeah
and so on top of that list should be not
touching your phone
right the left first half an hour to
last half an hour of a day
you know that should be something there
certain things that you just won't won't
indulge in
or and you know what you could do is
just when it comes to your brain i spoke
on the brain i always wear brain shirts
because i think it's so important to
take care of your brain
is ask yourself is this good for my
brain or is this bad for my brain you
know before every activity
or food that you eat or things that
thoughts that you have
people that you spend time with because
you know it's kind of warren buffett has
this thing where he
says thought experiment says when you're
16 imagine you're gifted a car
but this car is the car you're gonna
have for the rest of your life you know
how well would you take care of that car
yeah you know you would right think
about it the vehicle we
have is our body you know our mind and
we got to take care of it so
the first thing i do is i i come up
with this thought experiment that i came
up with years ago and i said okay
instead of just waking up and hoping i
have a great day
what what has to happen in order for me
to feel that way
my friend clay bear he has this
champagne moment idea
he says that when they crack open
champagne at a sporting event
it's very clear who won right and what
has to happen on the scoreboard for you
to just be celebrating yeah yeah
but we don't have that for our life and
we don't even have that for our day
yeah so imagine you're coming back at
home and you know your fiance
asks how was your day and you're like
today was amazing yeah and then just ask
yourself
what had to happen in order for me to
feel that way you know piss her off if
every day yeah yeah yeah yeah oh i can't
wait for this
but there's three things like you know
maybe three things that work three
things for personal and they don't have
to be big things but just
come maybe come up with those things
before you get out of bed and just say
hey these three things if i do
this this and this then it was a great
day and then get out of bed
next thing you could do make your bed
and that's so simple and
it's so no brainer but i believe are you
the initial make your bed guy
yeah you've been talking about it for 20
years jordan peterson is also
you know jordan peterson right yeah he
has also popularized make your bed
yeah but he might be taking your
material i i don't i don't know that i
need to sit down with no no no i
wouldn't say he
he is i mean it's it's it's obviously
many people make their bed so i'm not i
don't know
i thought you started it no you know i
thought people weren't making their bets
before until i started
yeah that's the fun part about going to
the hotel
that is made yeah there you go i mean
who doesn't love a well-made bed right
yeah but um your brain loves a clean
environment and my things
is all about your brain so you do it
because your brain loves a clean
environment and
i believe excellence is a habit that if
you could take two minutes do it well
you could potentially take that habit
into other areas of your life
i have never made my bed yeah in my
whole life
what i've never made it sometimes if a
girl was coming over i would just like
do this with the blanket
yeah and then i'd set it i do not make
the bet it's so weird
yeah what if you did like one time
like what if what if tomorrow yeah like
you know after you guys get up and you
just started making
with that freaker out guys if i become a
billionaire because i started making
yeah i'm not making that claim either
no she actually makes the bet yeah and
that's something that like a habit that
she's built don't get me wrong it looks
great
it's awesome i love it yeah yeah um
i'm not saying i know whether or not
elon musk and everybody makes their bed
and everything else like that normally
will make that claim
but i would just say test it out i mean
every once in a while like throw through
a curveball and start making the bed and
just like
you know is there something about like
having a success in the beginning
of the day yeah i think there's a
science of momentum
right yeah and success breeds success
yeah and if you get good at things that
really don't matter
then you could take that into the things
that that do you know even little things
like right after that
um drinking water simple thing but right
the night before i'll put a glass of
water there like in my bed
like in the nightstand yeah and i'll
drink it because you could lose up to a
pound of weight
just through respiration and
perspiration you know just
losing water and staying hydrated your
brain is 75
water yeah it's so a no-brainer it can
boost your reaction
speed your thinking speed 15 to 30
percent
just staying hydrated man like and you
have a lot of water you know at the
table here but just
drink some water i when i do it i just
down a couple of probiotics
because that's good for your your second
brain which is your gut yeah
you know and then i do three-minute
exercise and there's a next there's a
study done at appalachian state
university and we get a little geeky
here but they said
for weight management and better sleep
when's the best time to exercise
morning afternoon or evening and they
tested groups at seven a.m
one pm and seven pm and they found it
was seven a.m
it doesn't have to be your full workout
but if you just did three minutes of
you know what's good for your heart it's
gonna be good for your head get some
blood flow and oxygen there push-ups
sit up something like that yeah yeah
burpees uh jumping jacks whatever for
three minutes
then those individuals got upwards of 75
percent
deeper sleep and just doing that for a
few minutes first thing in the morning
you know and so jump starts your
metabolism you get some oxygen in your
in your brain
they slept deeper the next night even
though they were
working out that night doing seven yeah
and the most important thing you do for
your sleep actually is get sunlight
if you and it's tough sometimes during
the seasons
but you can expose yourself to a few
minutes of it's
resets your circadian rhythm so if you
have sleep issues getting
in what is that i've heard that before
circadian rhythm what is it yeah it's
it's a 24-hour biological clock that we
have
and so that's why it's so important to
have consistency but it's hard
you know this uh you know with all the
whole pandemic and everything
people are stressed is that like jet lag
is difficult
because that you're you know and that
really you know when i talk about my
sleep issues going to different
continents
you know and touring and and doing those
things you know sleeping in foreign
environments like
you know it's really bad when you're a
memory expert you wake up you don't
remember what city
you know i mean you're in some kind of
stale hotel room and you have you know
getting that night and everything and
it's you know
it's tough but it could really mess up
those rhythms and then
you just you're on different times so
your brain has its own clock
yeah and it knows what time it likes to
go to bed and knows the time it likes to
wake up
yeah and there's all these like cues in
the environment to let us know when it's
time even though
these outside sources like our phones
and like our air conditioning our heat
in our home
are kind of manipulating that circadian
rhythm a bit of what was natural
organic before right so if we're like
you're saying we're out there like
camping
right yeah there's going to be things
that wake us up a [ __ ] wolf is gonna
howl
like that has to be kind of baked into
our sleep you're not supposed to sleep
eight hours straight through you'd die
yeah i mean you think certain things
that wake you up and so sound makes a
difference also as well so you have
light you have temperature
i guess what i'm saying is like we
should be able to like wake up a little
bit and go back to sleep but yeah that
should be baked into our day
falling back to sleep is different you
know like a lot of people could go
uh some people have trouble falling
asleep how's that for you i think i'm
pretty good there
yeah so the latency it happens within
you know unless i have to wake up early
yeah and then there's that anxiety of
like uh now it's only five hours of
sleep
yeah four hours so the rumination of
that that could create
and then that stress puts you in the
sympathetic mode
and takes you out of that
parasympathetic parasympathetic rest and
digest
you know that's what happens what do you
got for that what do we do then yeah
yeah so
we're worried about yeah do you wake so
if you wake up um in the middle of the
night
right to go to the bathroom or whatever
do you can you fall back to sleep yeah
oh so that's great because a lot of
people they're they're their challenges
they can't fall asleep
insomnia or they wake up and they can't
fall back to sleep in the middle of the
night or stay asleep
you know and then that's different you
know one of the simple things people
could do
for falling to sleep uh whether it's
middle night or not is just doing
a simple relaxation exercise of scanning
your body
and just going from you know your toes
to the top of your head
and just say it's like something simple
like thank you toes
and go to your feet your ankle something
like that but most people won't make it
all the way through they'll just fall
asleep because it's such a boring
process
you know anybody gets them in their body
as opposed to in their mind yeah kind of
like counting
you know sheep or whatever that's what i
do i try to like just count breaths
it like kind of pseudo meditation type
thing but for whatever reason i'd stop
thinking about whatever i was worried
about and i'd kind of focus on the
breaths and
yeah it would work yeah i guess yeah i
guess
a little bit okay so that is your
sleeping routine so
i then i get up and i do the exercise
and then um
simple things that you mentioned even in
passing simple things to challenge your
brain
like brushing your teeth you know yeah
so that i probably originated over 20
years ago
brushing your teeth with the opposite
hand and you know i'm a big proponent
because
when you use a different part of your
body it actually stimulates a different
part of your brain
and we know that that if somebody has a
stroke or a head trauma on one part of
their side of their brain
if there's paralysis it'll happen on the
other side that one side of your brain
controls the opposite side of your body
but recent research has shown that when
you use the other side of your body it
actually stimulates that part of your
brain it's not one way it's actually
back and forth
there's a study that at oxford
university that says jugglers
learning to juggle actually builds makes
your brain bigger you create more white
matter i don't know if you could juggle
but if you could watch i can do three
yeah that's that's amazing so just doing
that
actually creates more white matter and
so using your body as your body moves
your brain grooves
and so challenge eating with the
opposite hand or brushing your teeth out
so not only does it stimulate different
part of your brain
yeah but also it forces you to be
present in the beginning you're not
gonna be good at it
and so it forces you to be right here
and as opposed to like your mind going
everywhere
and being distracted and flexing your
distraction muscles and later you can't
pay attention on zoom call